yes
[Applause]
he wants
mary lynn davis swelling
[Music]
av
ok
my shape and status show
net shape milk
standing in front row
[Music]
because the front line wait
in sanaa is in carbon
evans
o la font
as line scene from
Failed car is
before light
for me it
is
that the existing one I
alone have made thousands
to the soul
bis
with good things to
let me go
melchor is to decide a diet
center vision
have this vision social
small
yes
you are
prison
in your car
on 21 efe
sunday
[Music]
I can live funds you are so alone
the sun
[Music]
man united
louis
[Music]
of your account
judging to
come
or not
fort
craig
[Music]
on the facts
the
strong dose nation'
[Music]
where
[Applause  ]